foreign
[Music]
keynote of ACL 2023 and I like the first
keynote of Joffrey Hampton this was a
little bit less controversial it had
some interesting points though and I
would like to share these points with
you right now the keynote was by
Professor Allison gopnick who is a
professor of psychology and an assistant
professor in philosophy and she had the
following idea she told us that llm's
large language models are not to be
regarded as intelligent systems so first
let's think about intelligence why
doesn't she like the word intelligent
well because she's a cognitive scientist
and cognitive scientists are in general
against the concept of a general or not
so general intelligence they are not
working with this concept at all she
said that we humans and other cognitive
systems have cognitive capacities so we
can do some things and cannot do some
other things and you cannot maximize all
of these capacities at the same time
some go against each other for example
we have known this from reinforcement
learning you cannot have exploration and
exploitation at the same time so first
let's not think about intelligence
that's the first message secondly we
shouldn't think of them as agents so
why are they if they're not intelligent
agents well they are cultural technology
they let you take advantage of the
experiences that other human beings have
acquired they're not very different from
language from books from writing from
the Press from Wikipedia or from the
search engines so why do we like to call
them agents so much well it maybe has
something to do with our history she
says because we like to pass on
information and when we're doing this
we're using a lot of fictional agents we
have been doing this in mythology with
Greek gods and we have been doing this
in fiction and instead of actually
explaining how nature works we have
fictional stories with fictional agents
but there we are safe because they are
so exaggerated or it's so clearly that
they are fiction that we don't believe
that it was really like that that the
fictional agents are not fictional but
with Chachi PD it is easier to believe
that it's actually an agent because we
look at what it's saying and it's saying
it's a AI language model a helpful
chatbot and there is much easier to
think of it as of an agent so how should
we handle large language models if
they're not agents they are cultural
technology so we should regulate them
like we have regulated cultural
technology so far we should be
regulating like we have regulated
writing through editors and um that's
the way in which we should handle them
and then she addressed the question when
does a large language model so this
cultural technology also lead to
cultural Evolution well her points were
that for cultural Evolution we need to
ingredients the first ingredient is
imitation the second ingredient is
innovation in large language models are
very good at imitation that's their loss
function they just are trained to repeat
everything they see from the internet
and they're not so good at Innovation so
there's yet to be determined if they can
lead to a cultural revolution because
for a cultural you know Evolution you
need both imitation and Innovation so
these were the most interesting take
from from Professor gopnick's talk at
ACL and if I find the recording of it
then I will link it in the video
description and I hope you found it
interesting and it sparked some thoughts
of your own so if it did then let us
know in the comments we'll read them so
see you next time bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]